everybody is on this razor's edge right
now there's so much tension in the air
it's being fueled by economic insecurity
and
the pandemic and this fear of getting
sick and the vitriol on social media
and everybody's just waiting to snap
they're not listening they're not
present
[Music]
the prophets walk among us we tend to
think of mentors and teachers
as these highly qualified aspirational
individuals but the truth is we're all
surrounded by teachers
all the time every human being has a
story to tell that can be instructive
and helpful
in your life being in in the recovery
community for
you know many many years you know i
spent all this time with a bunch of
marginally criminal drunks meth heads
crackheads
needle fiends and junkies but i became
very bonded to these people and i
learned a lot
when you open yourself up and you're
available to
what they have to say and you're present
i think most would be
amazed at what you can learn from the
people that are in your immediate
environment if you just slow down and
pay attention
right now in this pandemic we're being
compelled to slow down like the fast
pace of our life that we've acclimated
ourselves towards has been interrupted
and with that means we're having fewer
interpersonal interactions but there's
also an opportunity for the experiences
that we are having with those
fewer people to be more meaningful and
to the extent that we can make ourselves
more available to them that we can be
present
and listen it amplifies your own
inherent ability to be
empathetic and i think that's very
healing and i think we need that
right now we're so divided and we're so
acrimonious
to the extent that we can let go of that
and just remind ourselves to be present
and available to another human being's
experience
our own lives are benefited in the
process of that